Yeah,
well having been part of a military
during the time of a draft and then
having been part of the defense
establishment when the all volunteer
force was,
was coming in,
there's no question in my mind the AVF
is head and shoulders above a draft.
Uh,
these young men and women are fantastic.
I don't know if I'd have been worthy of
them as a young officer there that good.
Uh,
but we're on the sec just starting the
second generation of the all volunteer
force.
This is going to be very interesting
experience and I don't know how it's
going to going to come out.
Clearly having an all volunteer force is
one of the things that has kept public
scrutiny of the war,
uh,
down,
somewhat.
Uh,
I do think having said that,
that there is a place in our society for
sort of mandatory service,
not necessarily military service because
I think it's a good thing to give to the
country and I think it's a good leveler.
A people of all religions,
races and creeds can come together and
sacrificed together and give back to
this country for a year or two.
Uh,
I think that'd be a great thing,
but I don't foresee a return to the
draft as being a desirable possible
unless we were faced with a major
catastrophe.
Oh,
I,
I encourage them to do it.
I'd be very enthusiastic about it.
Uh,
as I say it is,
uh,
the young men and women who go,
they find that they're part of something
bigger than themselves and uh,
I think this makes them on the one hand
feel that they're part of something
worthwhile,
but on the other hand realize,
uh,
that we're all part of something larger,
and that when you see that you can do
your part within that context,
I think it makes you a better citizen
all around.
I think it shapes you very well for a
future workforce.